so after 10 years of marriage
congratulations by the way thank you
you and ryan recently uh renewed your
vows we did how was that in front of
another
nationwide audience right
um you know it was it was wonderful it
was very sweet and sentimental and
an important thing for us to
want to show our kids in a very formal
way that we're committed to each other
and we love each other and and share it
with the people who have been rooting
for us all these years what is your
secret to a strong lasting marriage
oh gosh i think there's lots of
secrets if you will but
making your relationship again a
priority
staying committed and knowing that
relationships take a lot of work and
time and effort and you have to put that
time into your relationship just like
you do a job
i think having fun together
laughing
is a huge component of a successful
relationship
living in colorado has been wonderful
for us because we enjoy an active
lifestyle and a clean lifestyle and
we're kind of away from the hype now
what advice do you have for people who
are still out there looking for the one
i think that you need to be open put
yourself out there and be open to the
fact that love can happen anywhere i
mean look at me i fell in love on
television
so what kind of tips do you have for
people who are going through a difficult
breakup
you know well that's why i'm here today
because i am considered i guess a
breakup expert in that i have suffered
uh very public breakups in the past from
the bachelor when alex dumped me on
national television
um and then very private breakups as
well if people are going through
breakups it's always important to
realize that even though you're human
and you should allow yourself to
experience the sadness and frustration
and anger that you might have
to pick yourself up quickly and know
that you deserve
the best when you give yourself a chance
and you demand the best that you you
hopefully will find the best but it's
only about putting yourself out there
and really making sure that you're
getting what you want and you need who
do you think juan pablo is going to pick
in the bachelor finale any ideas you
know i blog for parade.com and i talk
about who he's having chemistry with and
and who's standing out to me and i think
that um
i'm always wrong so mind you i'm
answering this not knowing what the
answer is i do not look at the spoilers
i hate not being surprised i don't make
phone calls and beg for the answer
i just see a very palpable and exciting
chemistry between he and claire i'm
probably wrong but